annalena baerbock sie war die strahlende
kanzler hoffnung kanzlerinnen hoffnung
der grünen und lass uns noch mal in
diese zeit im frühjahr zurückschauen
lidia als sie gerade nominiert wurde als
kanzlerkandidatin als sie strahlend
dastand und ihr die herzen eigentlich in
deutschland zuflogen ja man muss sich
das mal überlegen sie hatte zum teil
höhere beliebtheitswerte in den umfragen
als olaf scholz und armin laschet teile
der wirtschaft fanden dass sie die
attraktivste oder bzw
die kandidatin war die sie wenn sie
direkt wählen könnten am ehesten wählen
würden und man muss auch wenn man sich
den den absturz von annalena baerbock
anschaut auch erstmal ihren schnellen
aufstieg anschauen das ist nämlich auch
sehr interessant sie ist anfang 2018 im
januar 2018
parteivorsitzende geworden und
beobachter die sie aus der zeit kennen
waren überrascht davon dass sie auf die
bundespolitische bühne strebt und dann
ist sie innerhalb von drei jahren zur
kanzlerkandidatin geworden eine frau die
man überhaupt erst vor drei jahren
kennengelernt hatte und das ist schon
unglaublich erstaunlich und dann hat sie
sozusagen mit einem sympathie mit einem
sympathie schub ist sie gestartet in
diese kanzlerkandidatur und dann kam ein
stolperstein nach dem anderen es wird
auch vor allem auch ihrem team
angelastet sie hat ein enges team um
sich das vor allem aus männern zwischen
40 und 50 besteht da es nicht so viel
diversität wie sich die grünen das sonst
immer so erhoffen und anschließend
schuld die männer sind schuld oder einer
burg in dem er eine erste sonde ist auf
jeden fall robert habeck nämlich oder
also der fährt er kräftige jetzt in die
parade in ddr kann man sagen das ist
richtig das wird auch von vielen grünen
parteimitgliedern sehr sehr kritisch
gesehen schon am wahlabend war da auch
viel unmut und viel ja es wurde ihm
mangelnde unterstützung
unterstellt dass er nur für sich selbst
gesprochen hat während des wahlkampfes
und nicht einfach auch mal gesagt hat
annalena baerbock ist die beste
kandidatin diesen satz hat man von ihm
nicht gehört deswegen das auch einen
teilen der partei derweil bei hapag das
war doch relativ schnell offensichtlich
dass sie es nicht ist sie hat sich doch
selbst die beine gestellt mit der
plagiats affäre vor allen dingen mit
ihrem buch also ganz viele fehler in
diesem grünen wahlkampf gehen doch
tatsächlich auf ihre eigene kappe die
das ist richtig und auch nicht nur dass
die sachen selbst waren ein problem
sondern auch der umgang damit wenn man
mit grünen spricht die so ein bisschen
abstand haben und ein bisschen ja auch
ein bisschen kritischen blick darauf
haben dann sprechen die schon von
strategischen fehlern in diesen kern
team eben und auch von einem souveränen
umgang mit den medien die kritik eben
vor allem immer unter dieses negativ
gestellt haben dass es eine
schmutzkampagne gegen uns diese losung
dafür hat die autorin carolin emcke
übrigens vorgegeben auf dem parteitag im
sommer als eben gesagt hat uns blüht ein
wahlkampf nach amerikanischen
verhältnissen mit fake news mit dass
informationen und die grünen haben
versucht alles was an kritik an
berechtigter kritik dazu kamen darunter
zu verbuchen und das ist eben eben ja
das hat ihnen geschadet wie geht sie
jetzt selbst um mit diesem bitteren
absturz und wer fängt sie dabei auf wie
was hört man im moment aus ihrem engsten
kreis aus ihrem engsten umfeld ja ihr
engstes umfeld also ehemann war ja
sowieso ein wichtiger teil dieser
kampagne und der ist nicht von ihrer
seite gewichen obwohl ihm eine schöne
szene vom wahltag kurz am vormittag
spielte sich das ab bei der stimmabgabe
von annalena baerbock in potsdam das
sind frühe bilder vom bundespresseball
damals aber bei dieser stimmabgabe
fasste er seiner frau kurz auf den kopf
genau das hat unsere kanzler reporterin
kira ob man beobachtet dazu dennoch
einflüssen von h weil eben beide wissen
und da sind wirklich profis es kommt auf
die bilder an auf die inszenierung und
da hat er eben sehr viel mit gestaltet
an dieser kampagne
[Musik]